Oh honestly I don't know that much about
calm us what oh my god I'm excited by
his music but everything else he does I
kind of hate when you were thinking
Kanye you think of something like
shocking new I think creatively he's
brilliant as a person sometimes he seems
to be a little rough around the edges we
all know that Taylor lies now oh I'm so
excited
here we go all right mmm this is like so
eighties a roving video oh oh I think I
need to thirst follow Anna Taylor on
Instagram the house definitely sexy yeah
I like Tomb Raider she's a beast yes she
is ooh underboob is very in we're just
looking at the lighting she probably ran
track
no I like how are you feeling great it
would take like eight of my butts to do
that Wow
holy I'm not complaining no not at all I
thought it was just gonna like
encapsulate the male gaze so perfectly
but it's not he's like in this gym she's
athletic she's really strong I love
watching people dancing alone I think
there's like a certain amount of
confidence that goes with that this is
the end oh damn
yeah I wish he was going down on her
right there because I think she deserved
what she said Kazakh cat what the [ __ ]
why why but I like this I like it a lot
what is this I don't know I guess she's
a cat and they're all oiled up a lot of
question what would made the ship to the
cat face with all of the sheep are
follower here yeah oh I don't even know
what the words were about I was just
looking at sweaty bouncing but yeah Oh
as you should Tanya does make stuff that
immediately becomes part of the cultural
lexicon this last image was probably
this video and I saw it all over Twitter
it's inspiring because it's so cool to
see a woman who's that confident and
strong yeah like killing it her whole
dance was about exuding power I could
never achieve that body hey I mean this
is still a person it shouldn't be held
at the standard I was excited for
Kanye's next thanks god knows what it's
gonna be black excellence